breaking news President Biden mishandled
even more classified documents a source
confirms to Fox News AIDS have found at
least one additional batch of top secret
files at a location that is not his
former office right now we do not know
what is in these documents or when they
found them the White House given the
chance to come clean about this damning
new discovery but refused to comment
Nancy uh looked into whether any other
documents have been taken to any other
uh is any other office that he has
whether in Wilmington or Rehoboth I'm
just not going to speak to this I'm
going to let the process continue it's
an ongoing process and so I'm just not
going to uh to speak to this from here
it is more prudent and more appropriate
for my colleagues at the White House
Council Joe finally breaking his two-day
Silence about the initial batch of
classified information claiming he has
no clue how they ended up in his private
office
people know I take classified documents
a classifying information seriously I
was briefed about this discovery and
surprised to learn that there are any
government records that were taken there
to that office but I don't know what's
in the documents I've turned over the
boxes they've turned over the boxes to
the archives and we're cooperating fully
cooperating fully with the review and
don't expect any answers from the White
House the press secretary sidesteps
every question
how could anyone be that irresponsible
isn't that what this President says
about mishandling classified documents
the
definitely how can it buying be trusted
moving forward with American Secrets
because his lawyers his team did the
right thing but he had a closet with he
classified employers did the right now
again again
he was surprised that the records were
there he spoke to this
all right Dana the nothing to see here
crowd who talked about yeah there's only
10 as if one isn't enough to prosecute
um now we find additional uh a box we
don't know how many documents are in
that at a different location how does
this impact this investment
investigation so if I were in the White
House Press office I'd be like Oh I'm
out I'm done here guys I mean there's
nothing I can do because I imagine that
there's probably more right I wouldn't
be surprised and it's possible that
either the council's office or the chief
of staff has said all right guys
everybody look in all the places look
anywhere because let's say that it's two
or three months down the road and they
find another box and then there's
another box okay so then you have a
point of saying when you're
irresponsible that's what you said about
the other former president
um you have the fact that also that the
they delayed in telling people that it
that they that it happened and Ed
O'Keefe is a reporter for CBS News he's
in the white house uh press Corps he was
really frustrated today by the
stonewalling on the timing because okay
fine if you don't want to comment on the
specifics of the documents or you want
to refer to the council's office which
you know the council's office is not
going to comment so that's basically
like again saying that no comment but
the fact that they had the information
before the midterms they held on to it
it only came out later in January it's a
legitimate question about Communications
I don't think that one should be
stonewalled even if the answer is you're
right we should have told you earlier
that would be an answer but she doesn't
even have something like that now you
can argue that these two things are
different that they also classified
documents but this and but that but you
cannot argue that President Biden has uh
communicated it more effectively and the
phrase of like it's only bad when the
other side does it only goes so far
President Biden just got back to the
White House he walked right by the Press
Corps didn't take any questions but mark
my words he's going to have to answer
something about this and he might not be
able to read it off a card next time
yeah you mean the way it was just
reading all right Jesse you know
yesterday you talked about how you know
the office at UPenn had some financing
from China I think that in addition to
that Jonathan Turley says that in order
for documents to be removed somebody has
to request that they be removed for
those documents to be in the one
location and now two locations and that
Biden was working on a book on the
Ukraine
well I'm sure it was Ghost written
what Biden's doing I do know if right
now we have 10 documents and Counting at
the end of this he could have more
classified documents out there than
Donald Trump had at Mar-A-Lago right I'm
keeping a little tally here
it's funny that he was surprised to find
that they had these documents in a
closet I'm sure he's going to be
surprised when he finds out the Chinese
wired his family six million dollars if
you read the story it said they
discovered at least one additional batch
at least so there's more coming and now
we know bidenids could have been sifting
through documents stored at locations
yes Joe only goes to Delaware where are
these locations so he's got the UPenn
Center that the Chinese funded
the only other office I can think of was
the place in Georgetown you know the
place that Hunter got the key for him
and it was an office that he shared
there was a guy named Mr Dong from China
remember Hunter was bringing strippers
in there highly secured place where
Hunter brought strippers to have sex
with
and how secure is this UPenn Center in
the middle of Georgetown a hop skip and
a jump from the Chinese Embassy did they
have those like motion sensor laser
beams that acrobats and James Bond
movies have to Tumble over into closet
it's next to a steakhouse Judge Jeanine
I don't think this place is Fort Knox
and why is he all of a sudden moving why
is he cleaning out the UPenn Biden
Center
right and wouldn't you send staff to do
that why would you send
a woman named Remus Remus just happened
to be the former White House counsel
she's not some low-level lawyer she is
the top campaign lawyer for his campaign
she was the top White House counsel used
to work for Barack Obama and then she
leaves and she all of a sudden discovers
classified documents I mean I'm not a
conspiracy theorist you know maybe
Obama's trying to set Joe up so he takes
the fall Newsome goes in but it's just
funny how you can get also paid as a
politician so China can launder millions
of dollars through UPenn to pay Joe Joe
is bringing in a million dollar a year
salary that came from the Chinese
that came directly from the Chinese
okay all right Jessica I want you to
listen to some sound that we have uh
from Joe in 2018 I believe
look here's my understanding and I don't
know I don't have access to classified
information anymore I don't get briefed
Every Morning by the agency
okay well now we know that for six years
he's had classified information not in
one location but at least two locations
and that his administration both the
White House and the Department of
Justice made a decision on Mr
transparency to not say anything until
after the midterms when they knew about
it before the midterms that's not fair
so I'll start with it's obviously not
good that this happened he shouldn't
have had classified information no one
should be
using the equivalency between what Trump
had and what Biden had to justify the
fact that he did it it was wrong and
this is a very easy thing to own I think
Korean Jean-Pierre could have quite
easily had that conversation and just
said the president feels terrible about
this it was something that he was not
aware of he treats this very seriously
and has over his 50-year career we are
cooperating which is the central issue
here that is the difference I mean the
number of documents and we'll see I
don't think we're going to get as high
as a Mar-A-Lago count but
if right now it's at 10 and Trump was
300 plus and 25 top secret I don't think
we're getting to those numbers but just
say even one is a problem and I was on
yesterday with um former Congressman
Doug Collins and he made a really
important point I thought about how
careers are destroyed for rank level
military folks right that they they
can't work again dishonorable discharge
Etc if you mishandle classified
information that's how important this is
right that we treat people that way so
that has to remain front and center
there's a narrative going around that
the administration is getting off easy
for this certainly by the media that's
not true CNN has been wall to wall on
this to the point that it is exhausting
liberals really I don't want to see it
anymore we understand it's really bad
MSNBC is also talking about it
constantly talking about how this is
something that has destroyed the Merit
of what he would have gotten the bump
from going to the Border anything that
he's doing that is cloudy yeah who said
there was a border bump no what the
polling has yet to come out I just mean
that the ability Ford bump you know what
I'm saying the fact that he went and did
this thing that people have been asking
him to doing and to do and now everyone
is talking to this so it's no doubt bad
but I direct everyone Karl Rove had his
whiteboard up yesterday he made a very
clear case as to why Donald Trump what
he did and what Biden did are very
different and the cooperation part of
this is key there would have been no no
FEI agents showing up at Mar-A-Lago if
they had complied with the subpoena and
not stonewalled for months well now that
we've found out Greg that apparently the
Biden Administration hasn't been totally
honest with us Kareem Jean-Pierre
skipped Peter ducey's question which
apparently was teed up possibly to
suggest that someone had heard there may
have been a second box isn't it time for
them to go in you know guns are blazing
into the house and find out what Joe
Biden's got well you know what I say
what's good for the goose good for the
gander I didn't say that I never said
that I've never said that I only say
what's good for the goose I've heard you
say what is it with the Biden's leaving
important stuff everywhere right I mean
you got Hunter just leaving stripper
babies and laptops all over the place
and a gun yeah you got the the gun
daughter Haley leaving a gun in the
trash can you got you know you got the
laptop you got the diary Ashley's diary
in a halfway house so you got these are
all really important things guns Diaries
laptops and here's you know Joe's a
regular Johnny Appleseed with classified
information it doesn't
look I mean look at this
did you see this are those an additional
batches
let's take a look shall we my goodness
my goodness I don't know what are these
pictures of a uh of a Book Depository in
Texas it's it's 1963 Dana that's amazing
I know that's it that's like a young Joe
Biden are you saying I think it's
impossible this is a bill from the
uyghurs for hair implants he's been
getting his hair from the uyghurs look I
uh you know
I'm tired of being nice about this you
know I like because like when this thing
came up under Trump I knew that it was
nothing and maybe this is nothing to but
you got to go back and Jessica it was
worse it was a hundred times worse when
this came out about trump it was it was
you had a historian suggesting executing
Trump you had I think it was Michael
Hayden who actually retweeted that and
said I concur or something like that so
I think that it's it you know I'm going
all in now I'm saying execution no I'm
not gonna say execution not yet I'm
gonna wait for the facts to come out
but I do think that right now it's safe
to say that right now this is perhaps
the worst thing that's happened since
the Civil War it's worse than 9 11. it's
worse than the Civil War and the Red Hot
Chili Peppers combined and perhaps we
have a constitutional crisis we have a
constitutional crisis right now but see
the thing is we aren't like that I can't
even pull that off right
it's so easy to call them a threat to
democracy Mr 10 and all that but we're
just going to keep moving I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now